[__] sou he's going around now he's
got psychic powers he's telling
everybody he did he actually got them he
got some psychic powers s did a reading
for a mystery celebrity we didn't tell s
who it is we disguised his voice we
disguised Jeff probe's voice he didn't
know anything okay the reading was done
uh via Zoom as soon as they get in the
room together s starts the reading again
he doesn't know who it is I can assure
you with that person are you there I'm
here I'm excited for this thanks for
giving me a reading all right
all right so the first thing I'm getting
okay I see a man he's tall I'm guessing
he's a father this man's from the
Midwest and I think you might have grown
up in the midwest I see horses I see a
ranch um it's almost like Kansas like
The Wizard of Oz and your father's there
he's a tall man I almost seem like in a
suit like in a briefcase going to work
he was a good provider you knew that he
loved you but he didn't really show it
too much he hopes that you know how much
he loved you I'm a little Blown Away you
knew that I grew up in the Midwest and
exactly the state that I grew up in
Kansas wow my dad did have an executive
type job he did wear a suit and he did
carry a briefcase wow he showed love but
I got to admit I think in that era what
you might be getting at is is it wasn't
the kind of love I would show my kids
today right my dad was a good provider
there weren't any horses per se or
Cowboys but what's interesting is I do
live in a home that is very Cowboy
Centric I don't know if you moved to San
Francisco but I'm seeing San Francisco
no there's no San Francisco it really in
my life see so s saw that he had a
father who worked and wor clothes and
carried a briefcase but here's my point
what's the point of the reading I mean
uh I don't know they they told Jeff he
grew up in Kansas well I think the point
in that particular thing is that his
father didn't express love uh the way
Jeff would have nobody's father did s
was some kind the whole generation was
like that but but maybe Jeff wanted to
know that because his father never
expressed it there was some kind of
emergency in Jeff's life somebody
recently like had like a a pretty
serious operation like taken to the
emergency room or something almost like
a heart attack situation I'm seeing
really really bright bright lights I
think it's an operating room so I'm not
sure well my brother did just go to the
emergency room okay about 4 days ago he
really did WOW uh it wasn't uh
traumatic but he that's where he what is
the point of the spirits passing along
information that Jeff already knows do
you know what I'm saying s I could yes
yes great question um the point of the
emergency room was to let Jeff know that
they were there they were comforting him
it was you know his brother was in the
emergency room and it was very serious
and there's a lot of work to be done in
the future and Jeff is on top of that uh
Jeff asked s if he was sensing anything
else about his family is anything coming
to you about my family anything
that's going on I need to know or well
do you have a daughter I do cuz they're
just saying talk to him about his
daughter you and your daughter are like
almost like I think live past lives
together you guys really have a um a
connection that's like really like whoo
I got to say you continue to amaze me I
would agree with that yeah that Rings
very true and no one's first of all what
did Jeff say at the beginning he said
you know my father didn't give me the
kind of relationship I would have wanted
with my you know my father so of course
I mean okay you got you said do you have
a daughter children yeah I don't know
the guy he could have three I have three
I have three sons he I saw a girl and I
just saw the relationship and I saw a
soulmate connection with him I'm just
telling you what came to me I'm D you
are [__] you to you s moved on to Jeff's
relationship with his wife your wife has
her back turned to you uh with her arms
crossed you need to understand your wife
more you need to be more supportive of
what your wife's thoughts are cuz she's
sort of like we got got this thing going
but like man let me breathe too that
does not ring true in how you're
presenting it things are really good
there's a wedge there's well there's a
wedge someplace is it your sister no I
don't have a sister I'm telling you
there's a lady and there's a wedge okay
but there's some lady that's interfering
in your life right with your wife right
there's a a woman who plays a role who's
kind of like the Puppeteer a little bit
you got 50 things wrong and then all of
a sudden you go well no no no it's a
woman who's interfering I'm just telling
you what I I saw a wedge in there I'm
just telling them what I saw I I give
you a wedge right here wedgie when the
reading was finished s got to see who he
was talking to he didn't know it was
Jeff prop I am Jeff propest the host and
producer of Survivor hey oh wow there
you are what's up S wow I'm a little
shocked at everything you said I really
I'm fascinated to hear the analysis of
this on the show because out of the gate
which you started describing me I
thought Jeff the analysis is don't
encourage s he got nothing right he got
canc he loed out right you go you do
what every psychic does you go yeah
there's I think there's a problem with
you and your wife you're you're Crossing
you know I see her with her back to you
and her arms across well no everything's
good with my wife well there is a woman
there is a woman tell you I don't think
something there okay post
intervie s started to get very emotional
about his psychic
abilities I have nothing to prove just
me
personally I know that the afterlife
exists and I'm so happy that I was able
to
utilize um the other side who's right
intertwined with us within our universe
to help Jeff out as a spiritual post
analysis do you have a message right now
to your spirits who helped guide you
through that yes yes I do I just want to
thank you
great I'm just
so
thankful I'm just grateful for the light
and the love that they placed in me they
placed in my family my imaginary friend
and uh I will continue my best he's
crying over the voices in his head most
people go and get help on their behalf
you're crying why why are you so because
it's a beautiful thing it's like once
you recognize
once you can feel and recognize the
light and love of Heaven of what's out
there your life changes I don't have a
gift it's but it's not I am simply
tapping into something that we can all
do s has no gifts none zero I am special
though